قبل أيام فقط من بدء
الشتاء رسميًا ، يستعد الجيش الأوكراني
لظاهرة التجميد العميق
لن يوقف انخفاض درجات الحرارة في
خط المواجهة القتال على خط المواجهة ، كما يقول وزير الدفاع
أوليسكي ريسنيكوف ، ومن المهم ليس
فقط لأوكرانيا ،
إنه مهم لأوروبا بالنسبة
لهدف أوكرانيا المتحضر في استعادة كل
روسيا-  الأراضي الخاضعة للسيطرة بما في ذلك شبه جزيرة القرم
التي ضمتها روسيا بشكل غير قانوني منذ ما يقرب من تسع
سنوات في عام 2014. وزير الدفاع
يقول لشبكة CNN أن أوكرانيا بحاجة ماسة إلى المزيد
من الأسلحة من الولايات المتحدة وحلف شمال الأطلسي ، هل
تحصل على الأسلحة التي تحتاجها
الآن في الوقت المناسب أه تعلم أنه عندما
يكون لديك  لن يكون لديك ما يكفي من الحرب ، نحن
بحاجة بالتأكيد بشكل خاص
لأنظمة الدفاع الجوي كأولوية رقم واحد
بالنسبة لنا ، هل تم إعطاؤك
تفسيرًا لماذا
لم تصل أنظمة الدفاع الصاروخي باتريوت بعد ،
إنها مناقشة طويلة مع
شركائنا لأنها
معقدة للغاية و  أنظمة باهظة الثمن ، لذا
أعتقد أن باتريك سيكون أيضًا في
ساحة المعركة ولكن الموظف التالي  GE
أن المرحلة التالية تشمل حماية
شبكة الكهرباء من الهجوم الروسي المستمر
على البنية التحتية للطاقة في أوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
أطلقت روسيا مئات الصواريخ
في الشهرين الماضيين فقط ، حيث أدت
الضربات الجوية الروسية المنتظمة
بطائرات بدون طيار المتفجرة المصنوعة في إيران إلى
سقوط مليون ونصف مليون
شخص في  الظلام خلال عطلة نهاية الأسبوع
ما هي أفضل إستراتيجيتك للدفاع
ضد هجمات طائرات بدون طيار Kamikaze
من روسيا كل يوم نحاول
إيجاد أفضل الحلول لطائراتنا بدون طيار التي تمثل
أولوية بالنسبة لك لتطوير الطائرات بدون
طيار وتعتقد أنها يمكن أن تكون أداة مفيدة
بالتأكيد نحن بحاجة إلى طائرات بدون طيار
للاستطلاع ، نحتاج إلى طائرات بدون طيار
لضربها ، فنحن بحاجة إلى أنظمة مضادة للطائرات بدون طيار ، لذا
فإن الحرب الإلكترونية هي مسألة مهمة للغاية
بالنسبة لنا ، ولن يؤكد وزير الدفاع
أو ينفي قيام أوكرانيا
بضربات بطائرات بدون طيار بالقرب من العاصمة الروسية
الأسبوع الماضي هذه الهجمات داخل
روسيا بما في ذلك 500  ميلا من موسكو
للطائرات الأوكرانية بدون طيار
هو ما تدعي روسيا أن هذا ما
حدث '  أه مهم جدًا لا تدخن في
الأماكن الخطرة بمعنى آخر كن
حذرًا مما تبدأه.
أعطى المسؤولون الأوكرانيون نفس الإجابة المشفرة
بعد تفجير جسر الجريمة في
أكتوبر. أوكرانيا لم تعلن رسميًا
مسؤوليتها عن استهداف بنيتنا
التحتية لأنهم لا
يستطيعون ذلك  نجاحًا ضد القوات المسلحة
لأوكرانيا ، يقول إن روسيا بدأت هذه الحرب
ولن تتوقف أوكرانيا حتى تنتهي من
ذلك ، وسنحل محل CNN أوديسا أوكرانيا.